[Music]
tell me something what do you know about
Buganda in the third-world country
textiles Shepherds to outfits or front
explores has searched for it called it
El Dorado
thank for it in South America by because
if I don't I'm I'm the only one to see
it and made it out alive
[Music]
the world is changing that will only be
the conquer pain and the Conqueror
capital afar like you are a good man
like a good heart
it hard for a good man to be 18
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody hail to the king we
finally got a black panther trailer
let's break it down this is so awesome
there is a new round of the Marvel
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video just for the spider-man action
figures this is going to be so badass if
you're looking for a really serious
Marvel movie the tone of this is way
more serious than what you're going to
see in something like Thor Ragnarok he's
going to be the badass of the Marvel
Universe he's the king king of the
Marvel Universe
even though Thor will eventually also be
king now they have something in common
vision is Cate Bros with door now to
chala
is King Bros really all this trailers
meant to show you is the myth of Wakanda
the way that other people think about it
like Ulysses Klaw with Everett Ross
there in that first scene that's so
funny he's going to be great comedic
relief and a great villain is when he
says you've heard about this place and
Everett Ross who's supposed to be
working for the world Security Council
they're sort of like the governing body
that give the Avengers that our marching
orders he thinks they're just like any
other third world nation isn't special
about them that's because they've been
so good at hiding themselves in hiding
how advanced they are Klaw references
I'm the only one that's seen it he's
talking about age of Ultron where he was
able to get in and steal vibranium that
he then sold to Ultron which was used to
make vision so I bet Black Panthers a
little salty about that you are made
with stolen vibranium but the way they
cut the trailer with you going through
the falls here makes it sound like
that's how you get into Wakanda like
it's not completely underground
it's just inaccessible through most
natural geological means like you
couldn't just walk there if you wanted
to you'd have to know the secret
entrance you see and enter the balls
here it looks like it's part of this
larger fight scene with Michael B
Jordans kill monger character so there
are a couple people that don't appear in
this but it's most of the main cast and
you even hear his father talking to him
throughout the trailer they're going to
be flashbacks they cast a young version
of his father but the adult version is
also supposed to be in the movie
so it's either just a recent flashback
or he's speaking to him as a force ghost
the way the Black Panther is able to use
his abilities as king of the Dead
you see Danai gurira and
PETA is a koi a and Nakia they're just
two of the most badass Durham aloshy but
then you see this other one Florence cuz
Samba she plays a oh they look like they
are getting ready to throw down hardcore
and you might spot Daniel Kalu over here
he was in the get out movie recently
he's playing cobby cheif of Black
Panthers Security Council Forest
Whitaker he spotted earlier in the
trailer he's covered in heavy makeup so
he's almost unrecognizable but he's
playing the friend of Black Panthers
father who has now become sort of an
advisor to Black Panther since he's
become King and you see Angela Bassett
here she's playing Amanda she's a big
part of the recent black panther run she
is the mother to Sheree and sort of like
a surrogate mother to Black Panther you
have to imagine the King to chaka
remarried after Black Panthers mother
died then he had Sheree with his second
wife and she became Black Panther
herself in the comics eventually they
give her one of the badass tech suits if
you're wondering who's in this hardcore
suit that Sheree in the comics they just
introduced those they would make Tony
Stark jealous so I'm really happy they
let Sheree be a badass
we'll see how the movie uses her because
this is all about black panther being
crowned king learning to be king and
also be a good man like that's the whole
thing his father's talking about you
can't be a good king and a good man at
the same time you see that big action
set-pieces he just soaks all those
bullets of the people that look like
they're trying to get in and steal like
people that are not there by invitation
you also get a taste for his fighting
skills too he's master of pretty much
every martial art you could imagine one
of the reasons why it's such a good
fighter is because he'll switch styles
mid fight and he's very acrobatic so
that's what you see with the big action
set piece is he's taking down this car
with his big energy pulse another one of
the powers that his suit has that we
haven't seen yet so it's a lot like the
spider-man homecoming suit the way
they're playing that up oh there's all
these secrets about it that you don't
know you have to imagine that there's a
lot of technology built into the black
panther suit that they'll show off as he
unleashes his full power in the reason
why he's able to jump around like this
is because he's enhanced Super Soldier
style like Captain America using the
heart-shaped herb in the vibranium suit
by its very nature absorbs all shock
that's why he can soak the bullet that's
why he can land on the ground without it
cracking all of his bones it looks like
what's going on here
Claus trying to pull a giant heist
because he knows what's in Wakanda wants
to get to the mound which is what they
called it which is what they call the
meteorite of raw vibranium that they
turned into a mine so they just call it
the mound so it looks like claw is
trying to get back at that and he's
using kill monger because he puts his
comic book mask on that's actually
pretty cool detail and he blows the wall
out trying to bust him out of captivity
they jump back and forth between a lot
of wakandans ceremony and then stuff out
in the real world like him chasing on
the bridge them in the casino here this
is not inside Wakanda there is gambling
in Wakanda but there are a couple big
locations in the movie and some of them
are outside of Wakanda - black panther
looks like he's addressing the United
Nations in this big chamber here you see
a big map of Africa they've already been
in the world's spotlight because of what
happened during civil war - Chaco was
referencing something really big and
dangerous that happened a long time ago
it made them really ate their legacy
that's probably also tied to Klaus
previous encounters with them but you
also see man ape here he's part of the
Jabari Lance that's where he's from he's
a big Black Panther villain and you have
to imagine looking at this map of
Wakanda these are all a bunch of
different cities these are the Jabari
lands up here not everybody gets along
the door of Malaysia I know they look
really badass but the reason why they
were created is because they're called
the wives of the King so there's sort of
ceremonial wives but they're made up of
all the women from tribes all over the
map here so it's a way to get all the
peoples of Wakanda representation close
to the king because royalty is a big
deal for them it's a lot like the
British royalty you know when people get
married people have babies so there's a
lot of family politics in that too now
kill monger we don't know exactly what
his history with Black Panther is going
to be in the movie but in the comics his
father was forced to work with ulysses
klaw so when Black Panther fought them
off he was branded a traitor and they
were exiled it was extreme disgrace so
kill monger devoted himself to avenging
his father's death he became a big Black
Panther villain he also went to school
in the United States he's also very
smart so they're presenting him as a
worthy foe - Black Panther in the movie
so a lot of it seems like stuff that
they've referenced in Civil War like you
only get a brief teaser for Black
Panther Wakanda
history but now they're just building on
that but there will be flashbacks
there's even going to be a young version
of takaka they'll probably show what he
did when he was still Black Panther
because he looks about the same age as
Chadwick Boseman
so you have to imagine it's sort of like
Black Panther coming back after Civil
War in finding all this civil unrest
while he's also being crowned king and
challenged from within all these people
that are trying to tear down his
administration in the people outside
like Klaw that are trying to steal the
vibranium the synopsis reads that he's
going to have to rally all of his allies
remember Winter Soldier is still under
his protection as is Captain America so
we'll see where they pop up in the film
and they just showed up on set for
infinity war with Black Widow so we'll
see if she also pops up somewhere in
here too but this all just looks so
badass and it's so different from the
Marvel stuff that we've seen before that
I can't wait to see how they try to
incorporate it into later movies like
you see Hulk in a Thor movie what are
they going to do with Black Panther in
future movies they just did Doctor
Strange they're not doing the sequel
until phase four they might do the same
thing with Black Panther where they just
stick them in a couple other people's
movies until they have time in the
schedule to do a sequel they're not
obsessed with rushing something out next
year so let me know what do you guys
think about this I feel like he is
definitely going to be the new badass of
the Marvel Universe
there will be humor in the movie but it
looks like the most serious Marvel movie
that they've made in a long time it'll
be coming out in February next year so
there will be more Comic Con footage but
I'm not expecting that to really start
dropping trailers until Thor Ragnarok
comes out in November then they'll
really start laying it on so leave all
your requests for black panther bonus
videos in the comments below I'll be
doing some more tomorrow there's a bunch
of new spider-man that drop so let's do
videos for that stuff too and why you
wait for everything click here for more
black panther and you can click here for
more incentive or
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys tonight